on peut parler effectivement d'un
d'un film qui répond à une forte attente
des indicateurs comme
le taux d'occupation de la salle par
rapport aux autres salles par exemple il
ya des journées alors ça dépend des
jours etc
il ya des journées où le film black
panther à lui tout seul peut réaliser la
moitié de la fréquentation de madiana
mais c'est arrivé une fois c'est pas
tous les jours mais voilà donc c'est les
salles sont souvent complète le samedi
soir par exemple aux heures de forte
fréquentation le dimanche dans l'après
midi
voilà quand les clients sont disponibles
c'est là où on se rend compte que
vraiment les séances sont complètes et
de la même façon quand on a sorti face à
une furieuse par exemple il ya eu le
même type de rush
donc c'est voilà c'est ce ce type de
film qui une fois par an une fois tous
les deux ans crée comme ça un engouement
et le bouche à oreille fonctionne
extrêmement bien extrêmement vite et est
donc effectivement il ya il ya du monde
qui vient voir le film le soir et le
week-end les deux versions fonctionne
très bien la 2d et la 3d
ce qu'on constate en revanche c'est que
ce n'est pas la même clientèle la
clientèle entre les 15 et 22 ans vient
plutôt voir le film en 3d et
et la séance en 2d plutôt par une autre
un autre type de clientèle et la version
originale c'est que ça répond aussi à
une attente on a de nombreux clients qui
aiment voir les films en version
originale sous-titrée en français donc
voilà il ya des films pour lesquels elle
même la version originale fonctionne pas
et en l'occurrence pour blake tentèrent
même en pot ça fonctionne bien